i mean the kiwis uh kiwi system i'd had
dinner with friends every night at 7
30. if we really wanted to because it
was so predictive that's nice i like
that i
like when the arts are disciplined you
hear all the time i read lots of movie
books
these freaking people start these
enormous movies without a script
can you picture ben affleck sitting in
his dumb batman suit writing rewriting
on the spot batman versus superman
are you kidding me that is the that's
the least efficient time to be
writing the guy's in the suit he can't
even take a piss
but he's got a rewrite act three you
know i mean
it sounds to me smart ones it's yeah
aren't you the ones that are union
you're smart you're experienced you
know these things that's what they help
it sounds like it sounds like they
squeeze them
into into release dates it's well it
sounds to me like you
you've had it you've sort of had it
maybe you've had it a few years ago with
all that stuff that's why you're doing
your own thing
now do you did it get to a point where
you it was affecting your mental health
you think you think you were getting
anxious
and uh you didn't like how you were
always fatigued and you're doing
american shows or whatever
were you just tired did you ever flip
out bruce of course
i did i i i pulled in in new zealand
they call it
spit the dummy and the dummy in new
zealand
is your pacifier so i spit the pacifier
and just went
because when a kid spits the pacifier
they go
you know so in new zealand they call it
oh yeah
ah they go i spit the dummy and i did i
went off on a director
like i had never gone off before and
would you say
um he was driving me crazy there was a
a way that he was doing something that
uh
was just i i had i was not interested in
how
how he wanted to do it and so yeah i
i went completely ballistic on them it
was like the last
couple setups of the day and i basically
excused myself it was one of those
i didn't really walk off i was done
enough
and i had to apologize to the crew the
next day you know i got everybody
together first thing
i said look i'm an executive producer of
the show i'm supposed to set the example
right so
yeah wow way to nail that so sorry you
know that this director didn't deserve
it
so we want to treat each other with you
know
but it's what happens when uh it's too
much when something's too much
um when you've either bitten off too
much
and sometimes when actors go off uh
they're not pissed about the actual
thing they're mad about something else
there's a great outtake of casey kasem
you know casey's top top 40.
40. this one goes out to bruce campbell
spit the pacifier everybody
yeah he's here's a song called spit the
dummy spit the dummy and
there's a great outtake of him of him
going off on and they've got it recorded
of him uh
just shouting at some guy and in the
middle of it he goes
and where are those pictures that i
asked for
he was really mad about the picture the
picture there was some slight that he
had sensed
was that and that's what really set him
off but something else
right you blame it on so you weren't mad
at the director you were mad at
something you were just tired you were
whatever you've had it
i was tired i'm sure i'm very positive
that i would have worked normally
with that guy doing that what he was
doing under normal circumstances but
you know so it really yeah it shows you
uh mental health no question about it i
called up an email to a buddy of mine
and i'm like wow yeah maybe you should
hang up the spurs
you know because you really do it for me
if um
if the joy is gone then you're just
looking for a payday and then at that
point
well then you'll do anything